ok number one it was a bloody weekend
five children were killed in our cities
over July 4th weekend all of them black
children nine people were shot in
Baltimore sixty-nine people were shot in
Chicago 16 of those were killed 25 were
shot in Atlanta in you know one 24-hour
period on Sunday including an 8 year old
girl who was killed right near the spot
where Rashard Brooks was justifiably
shot in self-defense by police but there
have been protests going on there
because of that because of that
justified shooting of a violent criminal
and in the midst of all that chaos an 18
year I rather I should say an 8 year old
girl was killed shot while she was in
the car with her parents the parents of
the child spoke out at a news conference
watch this matter
get your own get your own itch I tell
because of burial they killed my baby
because she crossed the barrier to
Maddie you tell you killed a child she
knew not to nobody even make a u-turn
sure you're not be killing your own you
killed an eight-year-old child standing
then - now one of y'all just wanted to
get home - see I could cost you wanted
to do still wanted to get home so now
you watch that very gut-wrenching video
of grieving parents and you see in
tragic detail the total absurdity of the
black lives matter organization and the
destructive destructive movement that it
has helped to launch because BLM has
nothing to say about this child or for
this child or on this child's behalf
there will be no protests no riots not
for her not for any of the other four
children killed this weekend are they
any of the the dozens of other people
killed in general just this past weekend
in our cities now think about this nine
unarmed black people were shot and
killed by police all of last year nine
only a couple of those shootings were
questionable most of them were justified
twenty five people were shot in Atlanta
in 24 hours now
black lives matter tells us the first
thing the nine people that's a horror
worthy of rioting and protesting the
second thing the 25 is not nine people
in a year verse 25 in a day in one city
nine people across the country in a year
verse 25 in a day in one city which is
the the greater epidemic which is the
greater crisis which is affecting
communities more to reinforce the point
again compare nine unarmed black people
killed by cops in one year to nearly
twice as many black people killed in
Chicago in one weekend there are dozens
of ways to frame this nine unarmed black
people killed by police first five
children killed in one weekend now you
know the black lives matter if the name
of their organization was something like
police brutality is bad PBB instead of
BLM well then they'd have a little bit
more of an excuse to ignore the carnage
in our cities as they're doing but the
name of the organization is not police
brutality is bad the name of the
organization is black lives matter
they're supposed to be fighting for
defending attesting to the inherent
value of black life and and of all human
life that's what they would say I mean
they would they would claim that you
know they're not saying that all lives
don't matter there's you know they're
just they're focusing on this this
problem of black life being dehumanized
and devalued in our society that's what
they would say and if that's their
mission and they say that it is then
there is nowhere that this mission is
more necessary than in our cities
addressing the violence problem within
the communities themselves the person
who shot into the car where that
eight-year-old girl was sitting and
killed her that is a person who devalued
her life discarded it treated her life
as nothing most of these people that
were killed this weekend most of them
would have been killed for nothing for
no real reason either randomly or in
robberies or in gang disputes or
drug-related violence or for some other
totally frivolous reason yet you know
yes oh yes there is a real problem with
life being devalued in this country
black life especially but it's happening
mostly within these communities and BLM
has nothing to say because they are
frauds they are total absolute frauds
number two New York City's community
education Council District two had a
zoom meeting recently and you can
actually watch the entire video because
it's public record I don't know if
you're gonna want to do that because how
long you can stomach you know may vary
it's really one of the most nauseating
spectacles of SJW insanity that you'll
ever see if you're a little bit more
optimistic maybe you would say it's one
of the most hilarious spectacles I don't
know I can't find the humor in it as
much because these lunatics are teaching
our children if not for the
detail I'd be laughing too but the part
that scares me is that these are the
people teaching our children in schools
so let me just play one clip for you
just one example here's a count's
Councilwoman Rachel bro she taking
another council member to task for
committing the sin of allowing a black
child to sit on his lap now I'm not
joking here this is she's offended that
a white man's lap and somehow that makes
the other guy racist illustrate to you
that you think I'm excuse me you think
I'm a social justice and you think I'm
being patronizing and I'm getting
pressured for not being enough of an
advocate and I take that to heart and
that hurts me and I don't want to make
how to be a better white person I would
like to know before this meeting
adjourns my nephew on my lap was hurtful
to people and was you oh dear God dear
God do you see why I'm such an advocate
for homes going that these people have
entirely lost their minds we are
watching as leftism descends completely
into insanity we are witnessing a
collective descent into madness perhaps
unlike anything the world has ever seen
before
and it is it is at
at the at the tip of that spear is the
public school system so get your kids
the hell out of it right now and you
know parents will often because I'm I'm
railing against public school system all
the time because the school system is an
abomination in pretty much every
conceivable way and what I hear from
parents a lot is that they don't want to
send their kids of public school but
they don't have any other option because
they can't home school because they have
both have to work or it's a
single-parent household and they can't
afford private school what else are they
supposed to do and we're getting to the
point where I mean really any other
option send your kids into the woods to
be raised by coyotes okay anything would
be better really anything would be
better than sending them into the public
school system we are quickly approaching
a point where they're they're just it
would be difficult to come up with a
solid justification for wilfully
subjecting your kids to this number
three here's something check out this
viral photo of a maternity it's a it's a
maternity photo shoot which is a thing I
guess where pregnant women get
professional photos done of themselves
because people have an insatiable
appetite to see pictures of themselves
and any opportunity is a good one it
seems so there's a twist though here
here's here's the pictures and she says
as you can see her pregnant belly is
covered in bees the queen says the queen
is tethered to my belly inside of a cage
we just dumped the bees on me and they
naturally began to beard I was terrified
as I am allergic but it was worth it so
can I just say I had to mention this
because I'm as a beekeeper myself can I
just say that I do not endorse or
support the trivialization and
objectification of bees as you see in
that photo there I'm not concerned about
the you know the fact that that that how
dangerous it is for people that's that's
not my point
bees should not be objectified in this
way or commodified
or other eyes in the way that you see in
this photo here
I'm absolutely outraged by that number
for a mob of vandals in Baltimore tore
down a statue of Columbus over the
weekend
once again no attempt was made to
prevent it no attempt is being made to
apprehend the criminal as far as far as
I could tell
here's what the mayor spokesman said he
said our officers in Baltimore City who
are some of the finest in the country
they are principally concerned with the
preservation of life that is sacrosanct
everything else Falls secondary to that
secondary to that including statues okay
so now somehow we have that so there's a
you have to make a choice now you can't
do both if it's not a crime that
directly threatens human life then you
can commit it is that is that really the
message you want to send from the
mayor's office well apparently it is now
I want you to compare that reaction to
this in California where a white man and
a white woman painted over a city
approved BLM mural it was right across
the it's right across the street there
was an in big big letters it said black
lives matter and two people came and
painted over it and here's what their
Police Department says reading now from
NBC it says the woman was caught on
video by onlookers as she painted over
the words black lives matter on the
street in front of the Contra Costa
County Courthouse while the man appeared
to film her on his phone authorities are
asking two but the public to identify
the couple so that they may be held
accountable for their actions according
to the police chief the press release
says the community spent a considerable
amount of time putting the mural
together only to have it painted over in
a hateful and senseless manner the city
of Martinez values tolerance and the
damage to the mural was divisive and
hurtful so you just see and of course
that you know many leftists and the
media they're passing around the video
of these two people painting over the
mural and saying how horrible it is and
they finally found a a form of vandalism
that they disapprove of and it's
painting over a mural on the street you
know these statues that are being torn
down you want to talk about a lot of
time being spent is a considerable out
of time putting the mural together
it's just it's just letters on the
street okay I could have done that in 15
minutes that Columbus statue that was
torn down or some of these other statues
especially that are much older do you
know how much time they took to make and
how much pride these communities have
taken in them for decades only to have
this band of criminals tear it down
because they personally don't like it
yeah but that's okay but painting over a
mural now there now there is vandalism
that is just totally unacceptable
apparently well I hope you enjoyed that
clip from the Matt Walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you could stay up to
date on all of our future content